I’m Luyen, CEO and founder of DivMob.
I have a small team of game developers in Ho Chi Minh City.
We started our company three years ago with only five people.
Today, we have a team of 40
and our games have been downloaded more than 40 million times.
Our current big game is Epic Heroes War.
(In Vietnamese) I'm Minh, game designer at DivMob.
Epic Heroes War is so popular because it's easy to play.
Users can have a big collection of gods from many cultures
and you can have online battles with other players across the world.
Earlier, majority of our paid users came from the US and European countries.
They will pay a dollar or more on gems and upgrades within the game.
But in emerging markets such as Vietnam, one dollar is a lot of money.
One dollar in Vietnam, you can buy lunch.
We have always wanted to experiment with the pricing in markets like Vietnam, Thailand, Indonesia and Russia.
I’m Phuc, Chief Technology Officer at DivMob.
We are very happy with the results of Google introducing sub-dollar pricing.
We reduced our prices in markets where we thought people weren't buying due to price.
To support the new pricing, all we had to do was configure the in-app product price
on the Google Developer Console. It’s very easy to manage.
To highlight the new pricing, we created a new boss fighting feature
and offered it to users in sub-dollar pricing.
It helped us convert a lot of free users to paid users.
We saw instant success.
Our daily transactions have grown by 300%.
We have also seen our number of paying users multiply three times.
This is very important. Paying users are more engaged and you can monetize them over a lifetime.
Today six of our top 10 markets in number of transactions
are from markets where we have introduced sub-dollar pricing.
I always try to give my team freedom to be creative.
We work together. We eat together. We play football together.
We succeed together.
What do I want to do next? It's easy.
Make the best game we can.